you'll be lost for hours in the first
iteration of Dark Souls two's DLC and I
mean that literally because level design
is one of the most enticing parts of the
sunken crown DLC the entire zone feels
like a huge maze made up of smaller
mazes inside of it and that is a
wonderful thing for a sequel that
suffered from really poor linear level
design until now I was lost in the
sunken ground DLC and I loved it because
you see it's one thing to force your way
past hordes of enemies to get to the
boss at the end and it's another thing
completely to do that while trying to
maintain a sense of direction and a
sense of space the DLC forces you to
focus on your surroundings so you can
make your way through the level as
efficiently as possible so I cared about
the room with the spikes on the ground
and I cared about the staircase with the
walking poisoned statues of death I was
forced to care about my surroundings
because it helped me conquer the sunken
city to be lost is to be a must and I
felt like I was properly exploring for
the first time in Dark Souls 2 because
it wasn't just me against the enemies
you know it was me against the world so
at the level design is a really awesome
aspect of the DLC and as you can
probably see in the footage the world
can be used to your advantage there are
these blue switches that predictably
alter the geography of the level raising
pillars with hollows in the middle
giving you multiple interactions with
different levels of one elevator the
most satisfying way I found to use these
switches was with a bow because it
allows you to block off the line of
sight for arches in the distance or
maybe raising a pillar into a mob of
enemies and I honestly got this really
really cool Legend of Zelda vibe from
some of the rooms rooms which require
you to activate switches while standing
on different platforms movement and
platforming in this way is simple like
in the Legend of Zelda but it's
satisfying and it's incredibly effective
in a Souls game and more of this
geography altering and puzzle solving is
something I'd love to see in the souls
games it's pretty easy to dismiss some
of these enemies as simple but I thought
about it and you know each enemy had
something that made them unique in terms
of gameplay they all have one quirk that
makes them difficult to kill or they all
have some subtle way of
killing you for example the sunken
Knights challenged my established way of
playing with a strength build because
they never staggered some Knights will
have an aura of poison that punishes
your backstab attempts and the bogeys
throughout the level will break your
weapon forcing you into a backup weapon
that you're less familiar with and that
really added the feeling of adventure
going through the DLC I had to actually
change my weapon as I went through and
using a weapon that you're not familiar
with or having a backup weapon that you
have to resort to really adds to that
element of adventure you know you have
to actually use everything in your
arsenal to try and get through the level
and I'm glad they made it so that things
in this level really really wear down
the durability of your gear my favourite
enemy though isn't the Crypt and I don't
want to spoil it for you but there comes
this point where there's this surprise
and the enemy is really aggressive and
figuring out the secret to killing them
while under pressure was really one of
the high points for me so I'm not gonna
spoil it for you but basically they
chase you and you figure out the secret
to killing them and that feeling of sort
of thinking on your feet that was really
awesome
the main enemy you fight is this
variation of the sunken Knight and
that's one criticism I have of the DLC I
would have liked to see a few different
main enemy designs maybe to break up the
monotony you know there were different
types of knight but every sunken Knight
had the same color palette and the same
sort of model and every single one of
them was dispatched in two swings of my
hammer and killing the same style of
enemy over and over again felt like a
bit of a grind but there is enough
variety to give it interesting for your
first playthrough and I'm not going to
spoil the bosses in a first impressions
video but two out of the three boss
encounters I was really impressed with
both of them have a combination of
unique and familiar design and I was
really happy to see less humanoid and
more monster designs in the DLC one of
the most important things is that they
have this really fully fleshed out array
of attacks that keep you fighting for
your life the entire fight may keep it
unique and they keep it action-packed
it's not like you can just stand back
and heal there's one boss fight that
isn't great and you'll see which one I'm
talking about when you see it but in its
defense it's supposed to be fought in
court
so when you're actually fighting
alongside other phantoms I imagine you
feel like you're fighting your own
battle with the other phantoms you know
you'll be fighting individual enemies
whereas usually when you fight with
phantoms you focus on one enemy and it
feels like you're just ganking them
I feel like this fight will be better in
coop but you'll see what I mean so I
think we should finish this first
impressions by talking about the
presentation and I think I have to start
this by saying that from software you
guys are major teasers they gave
everyone access to the door of the DLC a
week before the DLC actually launched
and a locked door with the whole world
behind it inspires a lot of curiosity as
well as a small bunch of hackers I know
a few people who spend more time trying
to hack into the DLC than actually
playing it which is an adventure through
the game's code not many of us can
comprehend and because they taunted us
with a closed door with the entire DLC
behind it for an entire week one of my
favorite moments was opening that door
and traversing that first crooked
corridor they really did a wonderful job
with that that twisted Hall was such an
awesome distortion of space and the
Vista it opens up to was something to
admire I love it when games foreshadow
your final destination
or your final nemesis and the sunken
ground DLC does both of those things
straight away here are dragons powerful
breathing as you traverse the first hall
and you're also dominated by this
gargantuan pyramid inside a cave which
is really brilliant imagery and also in
terms of presentation the final boss
makes these constant interruptions to
your play all around the map that really
made me feel like this was the Dragons
home you know he's constantly slumbering
wherever he pleases and he made his
presence known and felt by not
particularly caring about the other
inhabitants of the area so the verdict
on Dark Souls two's first package of DLC
is that I think it's easily worth $10
for the fan that enjoyed Dark Souls 2
but in my opinion it's even more worth
it for the fan that didn't enjoy Dark
Souls 2 and you know the DLC can't fix
all the problems with Dark Souls 2 if
you didn't enjoy it but dog Souls 2 is a
different game than the original it
fixes a bunch of issues we all had with
the first game but it also falls short
of a bunch of ambitious ideas the DLC
brings back the awesome level design
we remember from Dark Souls 1 and it
realizes more of what Dark Souls 2 is
capable of it took me about four hours
to complete most of it offline so I
reckon it will take the average player
between three to six hours to complete I
don't know about you but I reckon that's
worth $10 and if the next two pieces of
DLC are as good as this or better then
we're going to end up with a package of
DLC that surpasses what artorias of the
abyss did and it'll be even cheaper if
you want to become a part of my inner
circle here on YouTube then you can
support videos like this one by clicking
on the bonfire and becoming a patron
there's a video on my patreon page which
explains how that works this week is all
about the DLC so look forward to some
more in-depth stuff as well as playing
the game for yourself overall though
guys I hope you got some good
information out of this if you felt like
you had a different first impression
than me then feel free to tell me after
all that is my first impression I feel
like I'm going to change my opinion on
some of this stuff you know when I first
bosses over and over again or when I go
through the level for the umpteenth time
and see how well I remember the level
design so if you had a different opinion
let me know I hope you enjoy the DLC
coverage this week and as usual thank
you for watching my videos you're
awesome and I'll see you soon